all the fine arts programs now in I
think pretty much 100% are based on
contemporary art practices and so very
few universities very few programs teach
technical skills or teach you you know
how to draw in a in a classical way so
they're actually not really teaching
anything it's hard to know exactly what
they're doing I guess it was ever since
the 1960s there was being this idea in
in the art world that technical skills
and ability just aren't that important
and that the important thing is to find
your I would say your political voice
but it's it's very strange to me that
this has occurred because it seems to me
that before your voice is anything but a
an off-color croak you have to become a
disciple of a discipline and an
apprenticeship and and learn the tools
and trades of your craft and learn how
to be an artist because there's a
technical end to that I mean this is
really almost an image of the world as
it stands now that the purpose or the
the stated purpose of modern especially
postmodern art was to free the artists
right to break to break away all the the
things that were holding the artists
back in terms of rules and in terms of
of just the way things were presented
but what ended up happening is that
there were no more legit legit amaizing
objective or you know strong
legitimizing structures around the art
the only thing left was politics and
relationships and status basically go
hard you know unders there's a big
literature on creativity and it's
strongly which I know very well my lab
designed the creative achievement
questionnaire which is used it's been
used in hundreds of studies now to
assess lifetime creativity and so I've
spent a lot of time looking at the
measurement of creativity and also
trying to understand creativity and the
literature strongly suggests that when
you impose restrictions on people it
actually makes them more creative rather
than less because part of what
creativity is is the overcoming of
obstacles you know imagine someone who
writes poetry in the Haiku format well
it's very very restrictive and obviously
arbitrarily Sol but the fact of the
restriction is partly what makes the
poetic form possible the same thing is
true if you think about
playing a game there's a there's far
more things that you can't do when you
play chest and there are things that you
can do but there's still an infinite
number of variations of chess games so
this idea that there's a dichotomy
between structure and rules and
creativity is is perniciously false and
contradicted by the evidence and when
you when you start to explore the art
world in the way it works is there's an
irony there that it purports to not have
boundaries on creativity and structures
on quixote but they're actually
extremely strict and they're hidden
there they're kind of this pernicious
thing underneath where we're actually
you you have to present things in a very
very precise way for it to be able to to
enter into the legitimizing structure of
the of the gallery